well British Regulators have blocked
Microsoft's 69 billion dollar deal to
buy video game maker Activision Blizzard
the competition and markets Authority
says the acquisition would have stifled
competition in the cloud gaming Market
the all-cash deal was set to be the
biggest in the history of the tech
industry giving Microsoft control of
popular game franchises like Call of
Duty and Candy Crush well let's dig into
this a little more joining us live from
Silver Spring Maryland is Ian sure he's
a freelance technology analyst who has
covered the video game industry now for
over a decade Ian let me start by asking
you on behalf of all of our viewers who
are wondering what is cloud gaming
so part of what's been very interesting
about this whole debate is this thing
you bring up cloud gaming it's actually
a little different from what we usually
think of right normally when you think
of video games you think of a controller
and a console plugged into a TV or maybe
a computer and being able to play your
games that way or maybe on your phone
cloud gaming is kind of like Netflix
right the whole idea is that the very
powerful computer is somewhere else and
it's streaming the video to your home
and you're able to play interactively
with the game this is something that's
very nascent it's been around for many
years but no company's been able to
really figure it out but it's believed
broadly to be the future of where video
games are going which is why the
competition Market Authority is worried
about it sure well that leads me on to
the next question because I'm curious
about the scale of the deal 69 billion
is that the largest ever for the
industry that suggests that this is
going to be huge
uh from what I can you know my memory
right which it's a little swiss cheese
when it comes to all the numbers but my
memory is that yes this is the largest
and and I think what's important to keep
in mind here is that even though it's
the largest acquisition definitely a
Microsoft's history and I believe in the
entire video game industry the reality
is that still this is not the biggest
thing for Microsoft right when you think
of Microsoft today you think of
artificial intelligence you think about
the computer software Windows all these
other things video games are an
important part of their business and
obviously they're spending a lot of
money on it but it is not the only part
of their business which is what's I
think very fascinating and maybe part of
why all of these Regulators are worried
about Microsoft growing even larger and
more powerful sure well speaking of
Regulators by my understanding to go
through this deal would have to be
approved by bodies in the UK but also
the United States and the European Union
and it already sounds like it's not
really just the Brits you have concerns
in yeah
no that the Federal Trade Commission
here in the United States has definitely
voted to say that they are going to
fight this as well and look this is one
of those things where if the government
says they're not going to allow it to go
through it eventually it becomes too
much trouble for Microsoft to keep
fighting and though they may pull the
plug it's going to be very interesting
to watch and in particular I think it's
going to be really interesting to see
how the tech industry responds to all
this because reality is that for a long
time a lot of these Acquisitions were
rubber stamped deals right Facebook
buying Instagram Facebook buying uh
Oculus all these other things that have
happened over the years and now suddenly
the government is stepping in uh
definitely at a time when a lot of
governments around the world are not
liking the tech world and they're saying
look we aren't okay with you buying each
other up and consolidating and that may
mean a new kind of way of Being for the
tech World very interesting Trends
indeed Ian sure the freelance technology
analyst speaking to us from Silver
Spring in Maryland always great to get
your thoughts in thanks for joining us
again on Al Jazeera
thanks for having me